so we played this tape for you last time
we were surprised by it we prefaced it
by saying every conservative appreciates
ted cruz because he's one of the
smartest and most articulate people in
the congress and he's conservative
but he referred publicly to what
happened on january 6 is quote a violent
terror attack here it is
we are approaching a solemn anniversary
this week
and it is an anniversary of a violent
terrorist attack on the capitol where we
saw the men and women of law enforcement
demonstrate incredible courage
incredible bravery
risk their lives
to defend the men and women who serve in
this capital
senator cruz was game enough to come on
tonight we appreciate that he joins us
now senator thanks so much for coming on
so i guess what i mean there are a lot
of dumb people in the congress you're
not one of them i think you're smarter
than i am uh and you never use words
carelessly um and yet you called this a
terror attack when by no definition was
it a terror attack that's a lie
you told that lie on purpose and i'm
wondering why you did
well tucker thank you for having me on
when you aired your episode last night i
i sent you a text shortly thereafter and
said listen i'd like to go on because
the way i phrased things yesterday it
was sloppy and and it was frankly dumb
and i don't buy that whoa whoa whoa whoa
i don't buy that front look i've known
you a long time since before you went to
the senate you're a supreme court
contender you take words as seriously as
any man who's ever served in the senate
and every word you repeated that phrase
i do not believe that you use that
accidentally i just don't
it's so tucker as a result of my sloppy
phrasing it's caused a lot of people to
misunderstand what i meant let me tell
you what what i meant to say
what i was referring to are are the
limited number of people who engaged in
violent attacks against police officers
i think you and i both agree that if you
assault a police officer you should go
to jail that's who i was talking about
and the reason the phrasing was sloppy
is i have talked dozens if not hundreds
of times i've drawn a distinction i
wasn't saying that the thousands of
peaceful protesters supporting donald
trump are somehow terrorists i wasn't
saying the millions of of patriots
across the country supporting president
trump are terrorists and that's what a
lot of people have misunderstood that
wait a second even even you're waiting
hold on what you just said doesn't make
sense so if somebody assaults a cop he
should be charged and go to jail i
couldn't agree more we have said that
for years
but that person's still not a terrorist
how many people have been charged with
terrorism on january 6th like why'd you
use that word you're playing into the
other side's
characterization that as joe kent just
explained allows them to define an
entire population as foreign combatants
and you know that so why'd you do it so
tucker let me answer you directly the
reason i use that word for a decade
i have referred to people who violently
assault police officers as terrorists
i've done so over and over and over
again if you look at all the assaults
we've seen across the country i've
called that terrorism over and over
again that being said tucker i agree
with you it was a mistake to say that
yesterday and the reason is what you
just said which is we've now had a year
of democrats in the media twisting words
and trying to say that all of us are
terrorists trying to say you're a
terrorist i'm a terrorist and so look i
don't like people who who assault cops
and and i
stand up and defend cops
and
the reason i use that word is that's the
word i've always used for people that
violently attack cops but in this
context i get why people were angry
because we've had a year of the corrupt
corporate media and democrats claiming
anyone who who objected to to the
election fraud and by the way remember
what was happening
can i just ask hold on you work in this
i just i guess i just don't believe you
and i mean that with respect because i
have such respect for your acuity and
your precision and i've seen it on
display i've covered you as a reporter i
know how you speak
and you have sat there for a year and
watched people use language to distort
the events of that day
intentionally insurrection
saying it's an insurrection is a
political term it's a lie i've
repeatedly denounced it and and when it
comes to look i was focusing on what i
normally say that what you aired was a
little 15 second snippet what i normally
say is violence is wrong peaceful
protest is right if you engage in
violence you should be prosecuted if
you're speaking you have a right to
speak i say that all the time
and i agree
so who's ray epps by the way since you
are a senator like there he and this
other guy are clearly encouraging a
crowd
to commit crimes
neither one has been arrested or charged
what is that do you think so i think
that is a very good question i don't
know who ray epps is i've seen that
video multiple times it's disturbing
he's clearly urging the crowd to violate
the law when you see the crowd start
chanting fed fed fed for him to appear
on the fbi's most wanted list and come
off it certainly suggests he was working
for the fbi that's not conclusive but
that's the obvious implication and the
attorney general and the department of
justice won't answer the question doctor
i can tell you i joined with a number of
other senators trying to get the biden
doj to answer the question why so many
january 6 prisoners are in solitary
confinement why they're being treated so
much worse than the antifa rioters and
and the people who committed fire
bombing and a year of riots across the
country and this biden doj
won't go after them but let me also make
a quick point tucker remember
while while thousands of people were
standing up to defend this country on
january 6 at that exact moment i was
standing on the senate floor
objecting to the election results
demanding that we we empanel election
commission to consider evidence of voter
fraud and i brought together 11 senators
to join me in supporting getting to the
bottom of that so of course it would be
ridiculous
for me to be saying that the people
standing up and protesting to follow the
law
were somehow terrorists i was talking
about people who commit violence against
cops and you and i both agree if you
commit violence against cops you should
go to jail yeah but you're not a
terrorist
you know you're not you're a guy who can
you know a guy who's assaulted a cop
okay so that's there's a there's a legal
difference as you well know better than
i do since you were actually in the
running for the supreme court
and there's a moral difference between a
guy
the reason i use that word is for a
decade i've used that word for people
that violently assault cops i used that
word all in 2020 for the antifa and blm
terrorists that assaulted cops and
firebomb police cars but i agree it was
a mistake to use the word yesterday
because the democrats and the corporate
media have so politicized it they're
trying to paint everyone as a terrorist
and it's a lie and by the way i've
spoken out vocally against your exchange
you just had they want to paint us as
nazis yes that's scary that is what
they're trying to do and i just look i'm
the one leading the fight in the senate
against this garbage and it's what i
have been doing and it's what i'll
continue doing well i appreciate you're
coming on tonight thank you very much
senator
of texas hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else